اتفقنا على اعداد مخطط يسمح للامم المتحده
بالقيام بمهمه تقييييم ستحدد ماذا يجب
فعله للسماح للنازحين الفلسطينيين بالعوده
الى بيوتهم في شمال
غزه اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره السلام عليكم بلينكن يعلن الاتفاق
مع اسرائيل على ارسال بعثه امميه الى شمال
قطاع غزه لتقييم الوضع وبحث عوده السكان
ويؤكد رغبه بلاده في نهايه قريبه للحرب
لكن البيت الابيض يجدد رفضه وقفا لاطلاق
النار ودعمه في المقابل لهدني تتيح ايصال
المساعده وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه
في رابط بالتعليق الاول وزاره الدفاع
الصينيه تطالب الولايات المتحده بوقف
تسليح تيوان وتؤكد انها لن تقدم اي
تنازلات في هذه القضيه واضافت انه يجب على
الجانب الامريكي ان يحترم مبدا الصين
واحده وان يقلص وجوده العسكري واعماله
الاستفزازيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي حسب
قولها الرئيس الفرنسي يعين وزير التربيه
جابريل اتال رئيسا للحكومه الفرنسيه غداه
استقاله اليزابيث بورن ليصبح بذلك اصغر
رئيس للوزراء في تاريخ الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
التال ثار جدلا كبيرا امام الراي العام
العام الماضي بعد حظره العباءه في المدارس
الحكوميه مسلحون يقتحمون احدى قنوات
التلفزيون العامه في الاكوادور خلال بث
مباشر ويصرخون بان لديهم قنابل بينما
اعلنت السلطات في وقت لاحق اعت قال جميع
المقتحمين بدون الكشف عن هويتهم حيث سيتم
توجيه تهم الارهاب اليهم الى
اللقاء